firstly thanks for being here on a
Sunday morning especially those who are
in the bar last night so the reason I'm
giving this talk is sort of well two
three motivating factors one is that I
really like metal you might have guessed
that the second one is that I one things
I enjoy about getting a new dataset is
that you taking what can what is
essentially a bunch of random data and
trying to make sense of it contextualize
it and put it together and form a story
around and so this idea of exploratory
data analysis one of the things we'll
knows from my talk is I have absolutely
no goal in mind I'm not trying to train
a classifier I'm not trying to predict
anything I'm not trying to rank anything
I'm just taking a bunch of data and
trying to make sense of it and the final
thing I'm going to be emphasizing during
this talk is that actually you should
probably try something simple first if
you've been looking at the program for
this conference one of the things you've
probably noticed is that about a quarter
of the talks named deep learning in
their title more of them mention it
during the actual talk and I mean the
reason is that if you want
state-of-the-art results that's where to
go but often you don't need
state-of-the-art results offer and
training these systems can take weeks
especially if you're running it on earth
or laptop I mean I'm going at the end of
this talk and they show you a language
generation model I trained for about 40
hours on the laptop even more work went
into getting it to run it in the first
place stabilized converge everything
else in this talk took about an
afternoon of work there are standard
libraries based around it everything
worked nicely and as you'll see the
results aren't that different so if
you're trying to do something simple
start with the simplest thing and when
you're using computers the simplest
thing you can do is start to count
things and that's going to be the theme
of this talk as you'll see so this talks
based around two blog posts I've written
you can find them here basically heavy
metal and natural language processing
the slides are also online and so is a
code used to preserve create all the
images diagrams and text you see in this
report you can find online here I'll be
providing a link to this slide so you
can check everything out there so the
overview is going to be what is why do
we use counting why is layers of
quantifying natural language difficult
how can we approach it using counting we
then extend these ideas towards
comparing documents so the first thing
we want to do take a document turn it
into some sort of vector how do we then
compare them and then how do we take
this further and actually generate
natural language from a bunch of pre
tain documents in an unsupervised way
before their preliminary a lot of people
have opinions about what should be
considered metal and what shouldn't be
considered metal I'm not going to get
into that debate for the sake of this
talk everything that I have in my
dataset is metal and I'm going to refer
to it as such that's simply to keep
things short because well there are
subgenres and their narrow subgenres
I'll leave out the battle afterwards the
data set itself came from the website
dark lyrics calm which is a just a
lyrics site centered around heavy metal
I scraped it all a payment in the end it
came to about a two hundred thousand
songs of which about a hundred hundred
ten thousand were English we find it
there are a lot of songs that switched
between languages as well so that's
something we'll encounter later on I
have no intention of releasing the
lyrics one because people could easily
then just clone dark lyrics website I
mean now that I've sent an email to the
website admin asking if there if he
would consider releasing this never had
a response the other phrases I don't
plan to release it is copyright I don't
then a copyright to any of these songs
and there may be issues around that so
I'm sorry if you are hoping to get a
nice data set of metal lyrics if you
want to get your own then it's an
excellent way to learn how to scrape the
web
except on the show so the court the
question is natural language is
essentially a sequence of characters
these characters form words these words
form sentences these sentences for
paragraph choruses verses documents
albums bands to hierarchical structure
everything varies in length but as this
makes it difficult to say anything
quantitative about it in the usual way
when we think about machine learning in
statistics machine learning statistics
are really good at taking an input
vector
comparing input vectors summarizing
input vectors comparing classifying all
of this there's an incredibly powerful
set of tools built up around that
through how do we take natural language
specifically the lyrics of songs and
turn it into a vector there are lots of
ways of those single way and often the
way you choose to do that will depend on
what document what you're actually
trying to achieve I got the screen size
wrong clearly but what which what I'm
showing here is a graph of one
particular attempt of doing this on the
x-axis we have readability so this is
defined defined as the ratio of
syllables in the words to the length of
document more syllables per word high
lower so higher the reading level less
syllables lower the reading level on the
on the on the y-axis we have the
fraction of words which are swear words
and hear swear words I've defined them
as anything doc anything Google refuses
water complete and straight away you can
see there's actually quite a nice
correlation between reading leaving age
and swear words if you swear more may be
swearing Manu so like the politics of
polysyllabic Lee you have a higher
reading age because of the question
everyone always asks the bandhas where's
the most is Five Finger Death Punch then
they come in at just over one swear word
every 20 words which is Quaker
a band of the highest reading age in
this set is pig destroyer whoever sort
of fairly non-standard structure and how
they sing they know this our first
chorus verse chorus structure and yeah I
don't know what else to say about that
what I'm trying to do here is show 120
different band labels on one graph as a
result it looks like a horrible mess
there are better ways to view this if
you leave the data set is online so you
can look at it and explore it to your
heart's content
so this is one one way of turning
natural language into a vectored it's
very specific though if you don't care
about swear words it's not obvious how
you would generalize this and why you
would go we may be willing to think
about how we would make this a more
general and immediately when you start
to do it you run into problems the
problems are is that the order of words
is incredibly important the classic
example in journalism is that dog bites
manage and news but man bites dog is
news there's also the fact that context
adding a few words here and there in a
sentence can completely change the
meaning of a word the meaning of a
sentence and there's also the fact that
there are lots of words often these
words are rare they follow from a
power-law distribution there are a few
very common words but lots and lots of
very rare words
so we've beaded too it's not immediately
obvious how to form this vector that you
want to represent the document with and
the solution we're going to apply in the
classic solution to this problem is to
ignore it all and just count words and
yeah this is more or less a summary of
my talk and to see how far we can get
this this is known as the bag of words
approach what it means is you take a
take takes a bunch of documents count
how many times each word appears in that
document your vector describing that
document is then just a vector of word
frequencies maybe with some weightings
so what does metal look like metal looks
like this this is so I got done some
struts top words removal
but other than that I'm just counted the
all the words of my corpus part of them
size of the word is related to the
frequency of occurrence and if we look
at it we can see see a few things we can
see that real-life now these are fairly
common words in every in everyday
language but you see dead pain die death
blood they appear quite a lot as well
maybe more than we'd expect and from
this we start to get a feel for what
what may be the major themes in heavy
metal might be and this makes sense to
us because if you're an English speaker
you have some you've read English
documents before you have some implicit
understanding of how frequently a word
should appear in the English language
and this is quite a nice idea can we
make it explicit and the way we make
this is listed in for a computer to
understand is we take a standard English
text for the sake here I've taken the
brown corpus which is a standard set of
documents newspaper articles things like
that and I've counted the frequency of
words occurring in there I've done
exactly the same for my metal corpus
I've taken words that occur in both of
them more than five times for each and
I've defined the metric which I'm going
to call metalness and it's simply the
rate the logarithm of the ratio of the
frequency of the word metal corpus and
frequency the word in the English corpus
and I haven't fought any name for a good
unit for this yet if you have a good
name let me know still looking but with
this we can we can find out what are the
most metal words in the English language
and burn comes number one cried vain
eternity breathe beast gunner demons
ashes so it's it's what you'd expect
these are if you know metal then yeah
this kind of makes sense to a pointing
out that things like swear words don't
appear because they don't appear in the
ground corpus originally these are only
words that would appear in the newspaper
in exactly the same way we can define
least metal words
love metal can I give and in exactly the
same way we can define the least metal
words so particularly indicated
secretary University relatively
approximate in Chairman what's most
amazing about this is these actually
appear at least five times in metal in
metal lyrics yeah and so there there are
a number of things you can do with this
approach so well this is one of what
this is could have sort of related to
taking a word in signing a score to it
it sort of common common theme in
sentiment analysis there are some very
simple sentiment analyzers which assign
words scores whether they're happy or
sad and then can use that to sort of
plot there's a really nice paper on how
you plot emotional arcs of stories and
look at how what the over over say the
course of the book the emotional arc
changes and we can do exactly the same
with meta we have a list of words we
learn metalness so we can we now have a
two-dimensional axis and we can see oh
sorry I'm getting ahead in myself
because everyone always asked this these
are the most of the most metal lyric I
can find in my in my corpus and infinite
darkness by tormentor it's more or less
what you expect you take a bunch of
metal words and you repeat them over and
over again turns out it's really metal
so I I didn't remove them they removed
and these are the right ya know verbs no
verbs on that verbs aren't metal okay so
you get it getting back to sentiment
analysis and metal analysis one of the
nice things you can do here is we have a
two dimensional space where we can plot
out how things change so this is these
are a bunch of Metallica albums and we
can see sort of how they've changed over
their career so you start
on the bottom with kilomole you know
pretty damn metal pretty dark and then
they go straight away to their darkest
most metal album ride the light which
that's what you expect and then after
that you see there on an arc where they
start getting happier they start getting
less metal in fact Master of Puppets
just and for all black album and they
sort of repents that's their those happy
album and then since then they've trying
to be work their way back down that sort
of metal unhappy space to try and
reclaim some some of their former glory
maybe all the way to definitely magnetic
I haven't take up a new album for
metalness yet the interesting to see
where it lands but there's nothing
specifically there ties this to metal
lyrics we can do exactly the same plot
for say Harry Potter and yeah it's the
the exactly the same thing starts really
happy Harry to wizard he's happy he
finds that his wizards then things get
less happy and less metal because as is
a metal for some reason and then things
things getting happier happier many
stuff getting darker darker until you've
got the Deathly Hallows which is
officially the most metal Harry Potter
book excuse me I feel I kind of feeling
you're trying to find the one bin there
or hover then they're actually being
awfully well leave they leave the
interpretation Ty Lee to you so yeah now
now we have a way of turning documents
into vectors can we use this as a way to
compare documents and a natural ways say
let's take free bands and count the
words and see what happens so these
these bands are Motorhead machine head
and diamonds head you can maybe maybe
see a theme going in the in metal band
names here and it's if you know the
bands you might be able to guess it but
you're seeing a lot of see turns out
quite a lot but see if here's just
because it's a common word in the
English language and not in my estate
stop loads January congratulate this but
its overall frequency met on it see that
little word with each value more
relatively in the others ed you've
almost predicted my next slide so we
don't to do it on metalness because what
because the metalness was trained on
these bands turns out most of the words
they use a metal what we actually care
about is how they are relative to each
other so what of what word appears in
each band which doesn't appear in other
bands that there are labels if you were
wondering and yeah so how do we identify
important words and we define an
important word is something which occurs
more in one band been in other bands and
quite a nice model for this is treating
it as a binomial distribution so let's
say you're sampling one word from each
band what is the probability that you
see that word more frequently than
expect it and this is quantifying the
log likelihood ratio or which is used
for G test if any any one here's a
statistic spam but what is thought is it
just takes the number of times the word
appears in one document compared to what
you would expect if you've combined all
three documents together and suddenly
things make a lot more sense you don't
know any of these bands this one makes
sense but yeah if you do then yeah you
can easily you can see why these words
are picked you can see that for
Motorhead actually what defines the most
style they verse of Ghana and AIDS
that's the way they sing machine heads
are all about the pain inside and
diamonds head oh yeah and yeah that
matches up with exactly what you'd
expect we can do something exactly the
same so they've taken sort of 120 of the
most common bands for me use of swear
words originally we've look we can we
can apply get a vector term frequency
inverse document frequency which is
almost the same as log likelihoods but
it's implemented in scikit-learn so
faster
and we can create vectors these are sort
of ten files and these are vectors of
10,000 units which correspond to a sort
of waiting between how often a word
occurs in each document with how rare
that word is in the entire corpus of
metal to get a feeling for what what
this is doing this is Motorhead's
orgasmatron I've highlighted all the
words which make up part of the vector
so you can see that so pain is
highlighted but it's a fairly light
color the darker the color the more
important the word is in terms of
inverse document frequency weighting
pain is a light color so it occurred
that means it occurs fairly commonly
throughout the total corpus but pain is
actually repeated several times in this
particular lyric
so the overall weighting of the
orgasmatron vector is high in hay and
it's also high in sadistic but that's
because sadistic is a rarer word than
pain and it only better only occurs once
it's very nice about describing the pain
vector don't know why small what I
expected to be doing on stage ever but
here we are once we have these vectors
we can define three of vectors relating
to every single song we can also define
vectors relating to a band simply by
taking the mean of all the songs they
produce and with this we can define a
similarity so how close they are which
cosine similarity we can do to saying so
we saw the band Motorhead we can find
nearby bands Alice Cooper and Halloween
nearby songs and what words define the
band the most so again we see don't know
eight Slayer death blood life and
surprising and carcass flesh pus septic
which if you if you know the band makes
perfect sense which is nice because we
haven't encoded any information about
what these bands sing about or what
metal it's through simply by counting
words and taking some frequencies the
computers completely inferred
what's going on and what makes these
bands who they are style they have can
you see this and you can't see it so now
we have a bunch of vectors we can
cluster them we can say okay which bands
appear close to each other you can't
read this so it doesn't make any sense
so I'm just going to tell you it
actually worked pretty well so we've got
a over here's a nice one power metal
cluster we've got a got things like
rainbow and do appearing next to each
other to make sense you've got some
fresh metal cluster over here bit of
black metal over here yeah so we know
with no no definition of genre at all
encoded in it somehow just by taking
these vectors clustering them in a
hierarchical way we have some
understanding of subgenres basically and
before going on I should say where this
fails so the major limitation of this
approach is that the vectors a sparse
and there's fast because words there are
lots of words and you can't in clearly
with the words I've taken a thousand ten
thousand words of these vectors because
of the sparsity you can't do nice sort
of semantic arithmetic like you can with
word to deck and things like that but
it's a first approach to class and
classify subgenres this is works
amazingly well and really easy to do but
there are much more sophisticated
approaches so LSA LP a word to back or
beef or whatever I don't know what the
most up-to-date is it seems to change
every month I'll let you do the research
and another nice thing we can do to the
photos is look at generating
language itself for generating metal
lyrics and if you think about how you
might sit down to write lyrics you'd
start with an idea you wish to
communicate a story a concept something
like that you describe this you but
you'd also try and impose the
constraints that come with writing a
song and sort of iterate between these
two ideas that community
Asian in style until you had a document
you considered good we can think about
how we might want to try and teach a
computer to do this but I have no idea
what a high level representation of an
idea or a concept would even begin to
look like so I'm not going to do that
I'm going to ignore all that and just
count things and the way we do this is
we make the assumption that language is
in isn't a tool of communication at all
it's a probability distribution over a
bunch of tokens tokens in this case can
be characters or they can be words just
some probability distribution describe
it sample from it that's how we're going
to generate that language the problems
in this it's if you have say if you're
doing characters you might have 40
tokens if you look if you have say 100
character long string then that's 40 to
100 possible combinations that you'd
have to give a probability distribution
for so you have to be a bit clever about
how we parameterize things but that's
easy we can do that we use Bayes theorem
and the idea here is that if we
decompose a sequence of tokens as the
probability of the last token given all
preceding tokens and then just keep
decomposing it until you've got a nice
representation like this even this is
too too long for what we're doing so
we're going to make another
approximation that's a mark of
approximation that history doesn't
matter beyond a few characters we don't
care and how do we then estimate these
probabilities we use counting again so
if we have if we have a say a free word
context of our Markov state what we're
going to do is we're going to count how
often does this be 3 characters occur so
notice is a two character state so we
look at what's the probability of
getting word n given word n minus 1 and
n minus 2 and we're going to define it
simply as number of times n n minus 1
and minus 2 occur divided by the number
times n minus 1 and n minus 2 occur now
if you're building sort of language
models or anything more complicated with
this you're going to worry about what
happens if this doesn't actually occur
in your training data it will use a sign
probability 0 and that might worry you
but we're not making a language model
we're just generating and sampling from
a probability distribution so we're just
going to stick to raw counts because
it's easy and what this looks like is a
graph from each state you move to
another state and this is and it is the
first verse of Iron Maiden
number of the beast and if all
degenerate lyrics are met we just start
here and we step through each state so
that what I saw in my waltz and you keep
going you created to create this graph
each each transition has weights and we
example through it so this is this is
the result of a four word context Markov
model I've colored it in terms of how
often it's a continuous block of text
occurs in the training text so if you
use through shorter context and has a
habit of just blindly repeating your
lyrics so yeah it actually works
surprisingly well I one of the things
I've been meaning to do is create an
online quiz where we show this to people
and show them at your meta lyrics and
see if they can work out which one but I
haven't got around to it yet and yeah
this is really good I mean we can
compare it to a recurrent neural net
which I trained for 40 hours based on a
single character representation and it's
better it repeats itself less but it's
not that much better given the amount of
computational power that was thrown at
this compared to the Markov model I put
detect code together for the Markov
model in half an hour works beautifully
this took a lot of work to get working
anyway I'll leave it there only I have
all the models online so it's going to
play with them generate your own text
please have a go but that's me and I'll
enter you with a quote I found that were
the only quotes I could find that
included
- I think it might be quite fitting for
this this audience formulas to stop your
heart and eradicate your soul I will
raise you from the ground strengthened
by the pythonic guards thank you
[Applause]